here's another thing I wanted to talk
about before we go into other things
okay is I just want to know how long you
were at SNL and then why did you leave
and all that kind of stuff I was at a
snow for a year yeah
one year one full season 40 episodes
yeah and I left because they fired me
and they didn't want me around there no
it's not a comfortable yeah I like my
time there and we weren't making each
other happy anymore yeah because I
remember you telling stories though yeah
how cool it was like you were like oh my
god Jim Carrey was here and we you know
or in you'd all these people that you
were like that would come into the
office and you guys would write things
and I just remember feeling your
excitement about it and then and then in
my head you know and I'll just be honest
with you you know I thought that you
were being treated poorly there I think
that number one right if you're gonna
hire good neighbor hire everybody okay
yeah number two you're the one you were
though didn't you start good neighbor we
all start a good neighbor ID you started
it you start I started a good name and
also on top of it I'm gonna say that you
know I honestly view you as a legitimate
comedy entity I think that you're very
talented and funny and you have this um
you're very nice guy but there's an
executor yeah there we go there's an
edge about you that yeah you know and
but let me say this too since you've got
left you've been killing it thank you
yeah I agree with you I don't I'm
killing it and no I don't think it's
like it wasn't a match it didn't work
and it was [ __ ] I mean we talked you
were and I don't know if you how much
you know this but like at the time like
Jade was opening for you and so I would
like maybe host or something or get a
guest by Y so there was a lot of like
Long Beach
that's where I would come with you and I
was in the middle of it like probably
before I got hired and my big comedy
team had been swept underneath me and
like taken away and I got left out and I
was [ __ ] wrecked by it I was really
wreck and I feel really really smart and
nice to me do you remember any of this I
won other words that's why I'm saying it
right now because I remember you being
to me even hearing about it it
devastated me because I liked you so
much and I'm like this you know I just
doesn't make any really cent and then oh
to see you in that state must have been
so [ __ ] weird and difficult I can't
even do it but you know what that's what
at the end of the day dude it's like
Jeff Richards not that I'm plumping you
with Jeff Richards but there's a guy
named Jeff Richards he was on MADtv
mm-hmm for seven episodes he's a good
friend of mine he got let go they needed
SNL for a couple years he got let go and
then he spent 10 years getting over here
trying to get back into you know getting
reps and trying to get back into the the
business because he was just so
devastated about it but now I see Jeff
on the road now he's getting booked he's
getting some she's getting some social
media following and he didn't quit like
he he's persevering and he had some
really fucked-up difficult times you
know not that you went through that but
what I when I see you you know
like on the build when I was driving
down the street I'm imagine and looking
at you after all the things I know that
you went through it makes me feel I'm
being real know what the cry almost I
know I know it makes me feel like oh I'm
not gonna quit you know you can't quit
quitting is that's when you lose yes
yeah yeah they've been a lot of people
have been like man you just got kicked
in the dick over and over again it's
like yeah but this is what I do I just
get kicked in the dick and yeah yeah I'm
really good at getting kicking the deck
yeah but you're also good about putting
your hands on your take after you got
kicked standing back up pitching right
into the camera and like the camera go
oh
that's my thing oh mama gasps oh mama
but um yeah I think I do I just think
I'm just really happy for you dude hey
is that when you called me about
promoting this movie oh they reach out
to for maybe maybe two years yeah you
can put that cap anywhere he's on the
ground now it's fine and then that was
very nervous I was like I know you have
a reach and you guys like people and I
want people to see this film so that was
really where it came out well you know
we and I would like to reach out to in
other ways like let's go get pizza and a
weird New Jersey here's what how you can
help me okay here's how you can help me
one day I know you tell me this all the
time right is is that and you know and
you know Pappas had a resurgence the
last couple years which I don't think is
warranted but going did that burn but
then it didn't I laughed
just as a defense mechanism huh and then
it's got a little bit of rage but then
it subsided and I'm happy again
that were dating today oh mama
[Music]